she didn't fall in love with you because
you remembered her birthday and bought
her flowers in Valentine's Day she fell
in love with you because when you woke
up in the morning you said good morning
to her before you checked your phone she
fell in love with you because when you
went to the fridge to get yourself a
drink
you got her one without even asking she
fell in love with you because when you
had an amazing day at work and she came
home and she had a terrible day at work
you didn't say yeah yeah but let me tell
you about my day you sat and listened to
her awful day and you didn't say a thing
about your amazing day this is why she
fell in love with you
I can't tell you exactly what day and it
was no specular thing you did it was the
accumulation of all of those little
things that she woke up one days and is
as if she pressed a button she goes I
love him and the same with the
relationship it's not about the events
it's not about intensity it's about
consistency